bonjour à toutes et à tous chez romain
gauthier j'ai cofondé l'école
démocratique de leurs nos écoles un peu
atypique qui accueille des enfants de 3
à 18 ans sans classe d'âge et sans notes
sans programme alors qu'est ce qui m'a
amené à cette idée atypique de rejoindre
ce projet de le co fondé sur non pas mon
parcours scolaire parce que j'ai eu un
parcours scolaire classique puis après
un parcours universitaire aussi
classique
peut-être qu'on peut peut-être regarder
plus dans l'enfance où j'étais engagé
très tôt dans un conseil municipal des
enfants et un conseil municipal des
adolescents ont engagé un prix appris à
avoir cet engagement social c'est un
engagement démocratique pour les autres
mais je pense que au delà de ça c'est
après un premier contact avec dr julien
et ce modèle ici au québec quelqu'un que
j'ai rencontré et avec qui j'ai
travaillé qui est un pédiatre social qui
a mis en place une approche innovante de
soins et de développement de l'enfant
donc sont de 0 à 18 ans
son approche est vraiment d'aller
chercher bien être de l'enfant dans les
milieux défavorisés
et pour ce faire il va à les identifier
les besoins les forces de l'enfant et de
sa famille et avec un pôle important
d'intervenants autour de lui un
éducateur spécialisé des instituteurs
des psychologues des des travailleurs
sociaux
ils vont vraiment identifier quel est le
plan d'action ensemble à mettre en place
enfin son approche et c'est aussi une
approche qui mobilise la famille qui
mobilise le milieu de l'enfant et ce
pour déceler les sources de stress
toxique que peuvent vivre les enfants et
donc y remédier parce que faut savoir
que les stress toxique les stress
récurrent pour l'enfant que ce soit de 0
à 18 ans sont délétères et peuvent
détruire le cerveau ou en tout cas
amener à ce que son développement son
volume sûrement important que ces
connexions synaptiques se fasse moins
entre entre les neurones
voilà donc c'est cette première approche
qui m'a amené à avoir un une autre vue
sur l'enfant et après c'est la rencontre
de marine locatelli de clara bellard de
réalisatrice de films documentaires où
elle présente des approches alternatives
innovantes sur les enfants sur les
adressant qui m'ont amené à creuser plus
loin comment ou au sein du milieu
éducatif on pouvait avoir des systèmes
différents d'apprentissage et donc
allemand parlé d école démocratique
c'est un mouvement qui existe depuis 40
ans à travers le monde il ya des écoles
qui se sont formés et ce sont ces écoles
qui accueillent des enfants de 3 à 18
ans au sein d'une communauté de père où
ils apprennent en auto apprentissage et
où l'enfant autant que l'adulte à une
voie et représentatifs et peut décider
d'où va quelles sont les évolutions sur
l'école où va à l'école et enfin c'est
aussi des écoles qui met en avant ses
valeurs que sont le
là la bienveillance la confiance en soi
la justice donc je rejoins en en 2015 et
un projet en création qui est ici en
belgique de création d'une école
démocratique qui est constitué de deux
professeurs de parents
et puis en septembre 2016 on lance
l'école avec une vingtaine de jeunes
donc avec cette pédagogie qui est basée
sur les auto apprentissage la cogestion
de l'école par les enfants par les
adultes et le rythme de l'enfant qui est
qu'ils respectent et qui est important
et qui va lui permettre de dessiner son
chemin d'apprentissage alors peut-être à
ce stade de la présentation vous
demandez à quoi ça ressemble une journée
à quoi ça ressemble d apprentissage par
un enfant qui peut décider ce qu'il va
apprendre je vais prendre un exemple je
prends l'exemple de 2000 and un enfant
dans dans l'école qui a 11 ans et qui
arrive un matin à 8h40
il va aller au tableau d'accueil et puis
il va vous il va marquer sa présence
il va avoir un peu le planning de la
journée il ya des ateliers qui sont
proposés le matin par une maman bénévole
qui vient faire un cours de cuisine pour
des enfants en bas âge puis l'après-midi
il ya l'intervenant qui nous vient de
l'université qui vient proposer un
projet de création d'un robot et puis
aussi des cours récurrent qui reviennent
d'une semaine à l'autre avec moi ou
d'autres intervenants de l'école qui
allant donner un cours de math le matin
pour les grands et un cours d'histoire
l'après-midi et mylan a ce moment la
journée il pense pas je vais peut-être
aller au cours de robotique l'après-midi
le matin je vais voir autre camp voilà
il en est dans sa réflexion et il a
vraiment cette possibilité de dessiner
son son apprentissage notamment là sur
cette journée de ski va choisir comme
comme activité comme cours
c'est un peu ce qu'on retrouve ensuite à
l'université ou dans les entreprises
dans les formations vraiment d'être en
d'apprendre cette autonomie ce parcours
de 2 de poser ses choix et ensuite de
faire des apprentissages de faire le
tenir ses engagements et ça se retrouve
pas dans les écoles
classique traditionnelle c'est ce qu'on
essaie de mettre en place alors en fait
le centre de développement de l'enfant à
harvard montre que justement et prouve
que c'est par l'autonomie par le
l'apprentissage de l'autonomie des le
plus bas âge précocément et de façon
progressive que l'adulte peut amener
l'enfant à développer c'est ses
fonctions exécutives donc là je vous
montre cette image parce que ça montre
bien que justement on essaye d'être plus
bas âge d'amener les enfants à utiliser
les différents ustensiles qui peuvent
avoir à l'école et de le faire de façon
sécuritaire
mais de plus en plus son autonomie et
ses fonctions exécutives qu'on a tous
qui sont la mémoire de travail que sont
le contrôle sur soi que sont la
flexibilité cognitive le fait de pouvoir
être créatif de pouvoir rebondir
et bien si on les développe précocément
progressivement dès le plus bas âge le
cerveau va mieux se construire et cette
immense renforcer et fin d'année des
adultes plus épanouie dans la société
voilà donc le rôle que je jouais que
jouent les autres adultes dans l'école
démocratique de leur no c'est d'être des
facilitateurs et de d'amener les enfants
à apprendre à apprendre donc d'être
autonome et apprendre par eux même s'ils
peuvent le selon leurs capacités selon
leur âge ça va varier des 3 à 18 ans et
donc moi je j'encourage je montre
l'exemple je ne fais pas la place et et
je vais me retire progressivement pour
que l'enfant fasse par lui-même
voilà est maintenant en fait on va
essayer de repartir sur mme hilal parce
que on l'a quitté il était juste au
début de sa journée il a envie d'aller
rejoindre son meilleur ami
colin et pour ce faire il va passer par
les locaux il va chercher s'il est déjà
arrivé il va me voir moi je suis en
train de ramener des jeux et puis une
rame de papier avec des enfants
volontaires os 3 ans et et son frère
arthur qui arrivent tôt dans la journée
et il va nous dire bonjour et puis là à
ce moment là arthur mdir bat romain il
manque des des peinture verte est ce que
tu pourrais en racheter et puis là je
veux noté alain jada du conseil d'école
parce que on a confié des collègues de
madère dont je parlerai après après
millan poursuivra dans le jardin pour
essayer de trouver colin et là ils
tombent sur elin et ligne 7 ans qui est
arrivée un peu plus tard on a le droit
d'y arriver jusqu'à 9h30 dans notre
école et ils discutent
il lui dit qu'elle s'est encore est
encore en conflit avec louison qui lui a
pris son son pique nique sa collation de
10 heures et qu'elle l'a elle a décidé
d'écrire un mot et que ce modèle va le
mettre dans la boîte à meaux pour le
conseil d'ajustement voilà la discussion
est fait maintenant ils trouvent colons
qui arrive
c'était il était au jardin en train
d'observer le travail de la terre navets
labourer la terre hier et et ils vont
aller choisir leur activité livre tourne
au tableau là il décide que finalement
le matin il fait beau ce qu'ils vont
faire ces poursuivre un projet personnel
qu'ils avaient mis en place avec mort
harmonie de grandes 15 ans et 14 ans
c'est une construction d'une cabane donc
ils vont faire ça de la matinée puis
l'après midi vont se mettre sur des
activités plus à tel que tu arrives à
faire l'histoire le cours d'histoire
pour préparer leurs examens qui vont
passer en juin deux des douze ans le
l'examen du ceb
donc ça montre bien que on peut
apprendre de tout et en tout et est en
fait c'est ce que l'on sait ce qu'on
croit à l'école démocratique c'est que
est à la fois des apprentissages
formelle participer à des ateliers
il ya aussi des apprentissages informels
à aller dehors et puis faire du saute
mouton ou discuter avec son ami et puis
partagé sur des sur des sujets qui nous
font réfléchir donc l'enfant n'est pas
tout en conscience et d'apprentissage
mais dans une journée s'il est dans un
environnement structuré un environnement
qui a plusieurs types de type
d'intelligence à sa disposition
eh bien il va pouvoir apprendre de tout
et c'est donc ce qu'on va favoriser et
puis c'est ce que montre surtout les
neurosciences en fait les neurosciences
montre que en fait le cerveau d'un
enfant sa plasticité cérébrale est très
forte
c'est à dire qu'il va sans cesse créé
transformer renforcer ou éliminer des
connexions entre les neurones et que
ceci va permettre si ces connexions sont
bien sont bien travaillés de développer
son cerveau donc on va chaque jour quand
on arrive dans l'école aller vers ces
centres d'intérêts adultes comme enfants
moi aussi je la porte des centres
d'intérêts essayez de les développer
on va proposer des ateliers les uns aux
autres ou si on a besoin de ressources
extérieures on va les chercher un voisin
qui connaît le jardin voilà où une un
amateur de cuisine quelqu'un qui est
passionné de cinéma un chercheur en
mathématiques pour que ces personnes
passionnés puissent transmettre leur
passion et les les sciences ninian sauce
le montrent en fait le l'entousiasme la
curiosité la motivation intrinsèque sont
vraiment des formes hauteur de
développement du cerveau et ses synapses
ses connexions qui se crée chez l'enfant
elles peuvent se renforcer elles peuvent
devenir pérenne si justement
l'enthousiasmé là si l'enfant joue si
l'enfant fait ça avec passion donc c'est
vraiment dans cette optique qu'on va
créer l'ambiance de classe le mur de
classe l'ambiance dans dans l'école et
et mon rôle est le rôle des autres
intervenants des autres adultes et même
des enfants et donc de facilitateur pas
détenteur forcément d'en savoir mais
plutôt de permettre aux enfants qu'ils
puissent aller chercher
cherchez des par eux mêmes ou vers les
autres ce qui est ce qui les intéresse
et la posture est aussi très importante
parce que l'enfant assimile tout ce qui
est dans son environnement par le jeu
par par les apprentissages qu'il fait et
donc l'adulte qui est ici dans cet
environnement doit être un modèle un
exemple en terme de langage en termes de
gestes en termes d'attitude et de nos
convictions de curiosité de motivation
donc les adultes sont autant d apprenant
que des enseignants dans l'école et
heureusement pour nous on n'est pas dans
une quête dans une école où on n'a que
des enfants de 6 ans ou 12 ans donc on a
des plus grands qui vont aussi avoir des
interactions avec les plus jeunes ou des
plus jeunes qu'on ait des réactions avec
les plus grands pour certains sujets où
ils peuvent être même plus connaisseurs
connaisseurs que d'autres et donc les
interactions vont vraiment favoriser le
fait que tout le monde soit modèle ou
modélisant pour le reste du collectif
alors voilà un peu comment fonctionnent
ces auto apprentissage c'est un
apprentissage sans vraiment avoir de
programme
ce foisonnement dans la classe où tout
le monde est acteur après on peut se
poser cette question comment finalement
est ce que l on fait ça sans notes et ce
qu'on apprend est-ce qu'on s'auto
évaluer ce qu'on sait value et bien
millan le matin quand il est allé faire
ses activités de cabanes il était avec
morin avec harmonie qui sont plus grands
et demi morin et est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment experts dans toutes les
constructions de cabanes donc il a pu
lui montrer enseigné il a plus corrigé
par observation et l'après midi avec des
fiches correctives
quand il faisait l'histoire est bien là
il a pu aussi s'auto-évaluer vend au
prix vise vraiment cette auto évaluation
qui apporte l'enfant à se focaliser sur
son autonomie et au besoin on va
si c'est préparer un examen vers
l'extérieur vers l'université aller vers
des les évaluations plus formel
maintenant on est jeudi on a avancé un
peu dans la semaine et jeudi matin c'est
le conseil d'école dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
tout le monde arrive le matin et on va
ça semblait pour discuter de ce qui se
passe dans l'école tous ensemble enfants
comme adultes et chacun une voix chacun
peut voter sur les projets qui sont
proposés moi par exemple je vais
demander qu'on achète de nouveaux de la
peinture verte
il y en ad'autres d'autres enfants flora
timéo et oriane qui vont demander à ce
qu'on fasse un partenariat avec le
centre équestre local du village pour
aller monter les chevaux sont occupés
donc ils ont travaillé un budget il on
allait voir les différentes personnes et
puis on a par exemple aussi arthur qui
va demander à ce qu'un point du
règlement de l'école soit modifié là où
on mange à midi les lieux où on mange
donc cet exercice collectif permet aux
enfants déguisés leur sens de la
citoyenneté leur sens de la prise de
responsabilité parce qu'ils vont
travailler des compétences telles que la
collaboration la planification ou encore
l estime de soi la prise de parole en
public et en dehors même du conseil
d'école les enfants vont s'investir dans
l'administration ou la gestion de
l'école 11 en partant d'un cercle de
financement par exemple milanais est en
train de construire avec d'autres
enfants et adultes une soirée bénéfice
pour l'école pour apporter de l'argent
d'autres harmonies travail avec olivier
à l'aménagement de l'école et j'en passe
et ça ça permet aux enfants de
développer leur métal compétences qui
sont essentiels dans leur vie celle de
d'être d'être des citoyens engagés qui
tissent font confiance qui se
connaissent qui ont développé des inter
relation les uns avec les autres
des habiletés interpersonnelles qui sont
essentiels dans la société
ça c'était jeudi matin on à jeudi après
midi où là on a le conseil d'ajustement
qui a lieu un peu tous les jours et ce
conseil d'ajustement c'est un autre
organe très important de l'école pour
garantir la paix si et garantir le vivre
ensemble je vous mentionnais tout à
l'heure et linky qui veut porter une
plainte contre lui donc il y prend ses
collations et bien elle va venir devant
cette assemblée où il ya des enfants et
des adultes qui se sont rassemblés et
elle va présenter les faits elle va
présenter la règle qui a été
transgressée et puis on va écouter les
uns et les autres dans leurs besoins
dans leur ressenti et finalement
collégialement on va décider d'une
solution d'une réparation par rapport à
ce qui a été fait ça permet aux enfants
et aux adultes aussi puisqu'on travaille
aussi de 200 crée vraiment dans le
respect dans ce cadre collectif de ses
valeurs qu'on a mis en avant que sont la
bienveillance la liberté là le sentiment
de justice le respect les uns des autres
et les enfants autant que les adultes
donc dans ce type d'école en sont
garants c'est pas un adulte qui impose
des règles de façon arbitraire ou selon
un règlement mais ces enfants comme
adultes qui ceux qui sont garants de la
sécurité du respect là et du cadre
bienveillant alors einstein disait que
si on juge un poisson à sa capacité
grimper un arbre toute sa vie il va se
croire stupide et bien dans notre école
on a vraiment cette focale cette
nouvelle perception de l'enfant de dire
que chacun a un talent et il est donc
important de regarder chaque enfant
individuellement de cerner ses besoins
de cerner ses attentes et de lui même
lui faire prendre conscience de ses
forces de ses talents et qu'ils puissent
les développer et grimper à son à
l'arbre s'il doit grimper un arbre ou
alors d'être dans un dans une piscine
c'est plutôt un poisson et je crois que
c'est notre responsabilité à tous
adultes ici présents et aussi aux
enfants de de vraiment focaliser notre
attention sur comment les enfants
d'aujourd'hui demain doivent doivent
vraiment se centrer sur eux se connaître
soi même être ancrés dans leur
apprentissage ou leurs façons de faire
pour pour être des citoyens épanouis
dans la société en lien aussi avec leur
environnement leur nature et prenons
soin d'eux aussi prenez-le en prenant
les au sérieux car c'est eux qui
construiront l'avenir de demain
merci à vous
[Musique]